[Musique]
auditions publiques pour jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre bonsoir bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté donc notre
invitation l'invitation des chaînes
parlementaires de la fp et du figaro où
nous nous trouvons donc pour une heure
de questions réponses avec nos
journalistes d'abord jean jarrassé
marque réel
et puis organes mancini et du de il faut
et puis un peu plus tard deux
parlementaires seront là pour vous
interpeller samia ghali sénatrice
socialiste et patrick hetzel députés et
l'est remercie donc d'être avec nous en
ce lundi qui a vu pour la première fois
monsieur le ministre
tous les syndicats d'enseignants appelés
à faire grève contre vous contre votre
politique
quel bilan est ce que vous tirez au
ministère de cette journée de
mobilisation
vous avez peut-être un chiffre à nous
révéler et est ce que vous y voyez un
avertissement non en revanche c'est le
chiffre il faut fond il vaut mieux se
baser sur des choses réelles plutôt que
sur des disques ou le sushi c'est de
10,98 % de participants de la vis sur
donc sur l'ensemble des du premier degré
du second degré un petit peu plus sur le
second degré que sur le premier degré
c'est est ce qu'on a ce qu'on attendait
puisque ça doit être de leurs 2 8% dans
le dans le premier degré donc c'est ce
sont des chiffres qui sont anti sont
assez bas ça veut pas dire vous parler
d'un échec ce soir je pense qu'en tout
cas le discours sens ça fait une
personne sur dix ça ne peut pas parler
de succès mais c'est pas m'appartient
pas tellement de nous commenter ça
finalement si ce n'est que de te dire
premièrement que bien entendu j'entends
j'entends les uns les autres s'exprimer
je vois que parfois c'est fait avec un
peu d'excès personne n'ignore que les
élections professionnelles dans trois
semaines et que ça invite dans une
tradition française qu'on peut discuter
à une certaine surenchère
et puis deuxièmement bien entendu des
choses que j'entendais d'ailleurs que
jean je suis capable d'écouter depuis le
début alors justement on a été écouté
une également ce qui est ce qu'en disait
dans les cortèges de gimont est-ce que
ça explique les actions commerciales le
fait que toutes les organisations
étaient mobilisés on a front uni c'est
la première fois depuis 2011 que c'est
le cas oui est-ce que c'est conjoncturel
ou est ce que vous y voyez un signal
d'alarmé
bon je vois pas ainsi alain gilles voile
le fait que malheureusement en france le
certains pensent que la veille
d'élections professionnelles il est bon
d'être celui qui sera le plus radical
donc j'invite chacun à regarder les
commentaires des uns les autres je
pourrais on pourrait passer lors de
l'émission a expliqué l'histoire de
chaque syndicat pourquoi ils disent là
et quels sont les dépenses et les
éventuels arrière pensée mais le fait
est que je pense qu'aujourd'hui si vous
voulez le fond de ma pensée s'il y avait
un syndicat qui disait que c'est des
choses intéressantes qui se passe en ce
moment dans les réformes
il aurait peut-être un certain nombre de
professeurs pour voter pour pour lui et
donc j'invite certains réfléchir à ça
parce que je pense que ça et je vais
beaucoup sur le terrain la semaine
dernière j'étais dans cinq villes
différentes je vois beaucoup de
professeurs de l'école primaire du
collège du lycée
bien sûr ils ont des attentes bien sûr
il peut y avoir des insatisfactions les
professeurs dont je sois au contraire de
très grandes attentes
par rapport à des situations qui sont
parfois difficiles ça je suis le le
premier à le reconnaître il est démontré
qu'aussi sur votre politique on les
incompréhensions notamment qui domine
c'est sur la suppression de postes dans
le secondaire 2650 postes là où vous en
créer dans le primaire comment est ce
qu'on justifie ces suppressions de
postes alors que par ailleurs pour des
raisons démographiques je crois que
c'est laid les chiffres de votre
ministère 40 mille élèves chaque année
en plus dans le secondaire dans les
années à venir
vous avez des élèves en plus pendant
trois quatre ans dans les années à venir
encore dans l'enseignement secondaire et
des élèves en moins dans l'enseignement
primaire
si je faisais de la gestion à la petite
semaine je ferai une conclusion beaucoup
trop rapide qui serait ont créé des
postes dans le second degré et on en
supprime dans le premier degré ce serait
ce serait stupide
aujourd'hui la france est un pays qui
dispensent moins que la moyenne des pays
de ces deux sur son école primaire et
plus sur son second degré or l'école
primaire et je la fiche très clairement
et je l'assumé budgétairement doit être
notre priorité
y compris dans l'intérêt de
l'enseignement secondaire puisque on a
besoin d'aller à la racine des
difficultés des enfants pour qu'ils
sachent lire écrire compter respecter
autrui
en arrivant dans l'enseignement
secondaire si je suis professeur de
sixième
je préfère avoir un élève en plus ou en
moins que c'est pas ça qui compte le
plus pour moi ce qui compte c'est que
l'enfant arrive avec des savoirs
consolider et donc c'est toute la
politique que nous accomplissons à
l'école primaire qui est de manière
assez naturelle prioritaire sur le plan
qualitatif comme sur le plan comme sur
le plan budgétaire
vous avez un impact quand même ces
suppressions ne pas chasser plus mon
réalité aura pas parce que chargé par
exemple des classes surchargées ça peut
exister
avant les mesures que j'ai prise je ne
dis pas que dans certains endroits
certaines grandes villes il ya pas des
classes surchargées on doit porter
remède à cela
mais quand vous prenez l'ensemble de la
france d'abord nous mettons des heures
supplémentaires il ya 65 millions
d'euros dans le budget pour les heures
supplémentaires certains professeurs
auront ainsi une augmentation de leur
pouvoir d'achat grâce à ses heures
supplémentaires donc mais en termes de
taux d'encadrement pour les élèves ça
neutralise l'effet est donc c'est
positif
et puis le de la deuxième chose c'est
que si vous êtes même si vous si vous
avez la vision la plus pessimiste de ce
que c'est que ça produit comme c'est 0
2% des effectifs
ça voudrait dire un élève peut être en
plus sur quatre classes grand maximum
donc c'est donc pour trois classes c'est
neutre et pour la quatrième un élève de
plus c'est pas le coeur de ses pas le
coeur du sujet j'entends certaines
choses pendant ces travaux nous dit vous
n'avez pas dévié de votre politique
après cette journée n'est pas de traquer
pas une réussite vous l'avez si je si je
déviait de ma politique on pourrait
s'étonner quand même deux mâts de ma
faiblesse je fais deux il est il ya un
sillon qui creuse et qui est très
clairement annoncé depuis 18 mois qui
est conforme aux engagements
présidentiels d'emmanuel macron ce
sillon c'est celui d'une école primaire
consolidé d'enfants dont auquel on donne
à tous les savoirs fondamentaux y
compris dans les territoires les plus
défavorisés en milieu urbain comme en
milieu rural et c'est un collège et un
lycée qui permettent à l'élève de
s'épanouir et notamment de faire plus de
choix c'est le sens de la réforme du
baccalauréat qui est absolument
essentiel et qui se met en oeuvre
maintenant
donc il faut faire attention à ce que
ces mouvements nous ne nous amène pas à
nous concentrer sur des sujets qui en
réalité ne sont pas les plus importants
ce qu'on pourrait appeler les sujets
quantitatif
quand les vrais sujets sont les sujets
qualitatif sur lesquels il ya des
réformes ans les syndicats s'en est
rappelé à l'éducation nationale lors
être telle est la question
je n'utilise pas des mots comme ça je
sais c'est justement en ce qui me
concerne d'avoir d'avoir un vocabulaire
mesurer et quand vous êtes vous encore
des caisses qui est légitime dans leurs
revendications du coup qu'est ce que
qu'est ce que vous entendez vraiment
nous disent pas tous la même chose
justement mai
j'entends d'abord les craintes sur les
suppressions de postes j'ai quand même
des éléments de réponse comme ceux que
je viens de vous donner
j'entends aussi ce qu'ils peuvent dire
sur les conditions de travail par
exemple sur les enjeux de sécurité qui
ont été beaucoup dans l'actualité ces
derniers temps or précisément je
considère que nous avons une stratégie
qui permet d'aller de l'avant
notre volonté c'est l'élévation du
niveau général faire que la france
redevienne cette puissance éducative
cette force qui va grâce à son éducation
et quand on est con et ce faisant de la
justice sociale justice sociale
élévation du niveau général
c'est la politique menée elle a au moins
un mérite qu on peut lui reconnaître
c'est qu'elle est transparente
tout est sur la table tout est explicite
et de façon à tout simplement avoir une
stratégie de long terme
ça fait un an et demi qu'on est là on a
déjà fait beaucoup de réformes de
l'éducation mais on les fait aussi d'une
manière cohérente entre elles pour
aboutir à ces deux objectifs fixés
l'éducation nationale n'aurait-elle pas
pu être sanctuarisée dans cette réforme
budgétaire dont on parle cinquante mille
fonctionnaires qui vont être supprimées
il ya des secteurs qui sont touchés mais
pourquoi on ne conserve pas le on ne
protège pas l'éducation nationale ça
aurait pu être possible
elle est sécurisée parce que ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'il ya une
augmentation budgétaire
c'est plus 1,7 pour cent l'an prochain
il ya des super size me sens un oui mais
c'est là que je parle de qualitatif
finale de cardiff en termes budgétaires
secteur sensu ses 850 millions d'euros
si c'était une petite de pure gestion et
de pure apparence pour éviter ce genre
de commentaire en fait on avec ce même
argent on ne ferait pas les suppressions
de postes mais il ya d'autres choses
qu'on ne ferait pas or ce que je sais ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'on ait une
politique qualitative autrement dit on à
850 millions d'euros c'est une somme en
plus de l'année précédente c'est donc
une augmentation considérable mais avec
ces moyens là on mène une politique qui
sauf qui sait faire des choix qui c'est
cibler ce qui ne va pas par exemple une
priorité à l'école primaire donc ont
créé des postes à l'école primaire comme
important le rappeler 1800 postes créés
à l'école à l'école primaire il faut
mieux valoriser le travail des
enseignants quitte à fos en moins
nombreux à améliorer aussi le
le pouvoir d'achat des enseignants
améliorer leur rémunération n'est
engagée dans une politique très
importante sur l'ensemble du quinquennat
pour cela pour que tout simplement
notamment les enseignants qui rentrent
dans la carrière puisse être mieux
rémunérés pour rendre la carrière plus
attractive
on a des projets aussi pour le pré
recrutement des enseignants et puis on a
les transformations du collège et du
lycée aujourd'hui vous avez la mesure de
voir fait au collège qui permet d'aider
les élèves le soir et là aussi de
compenser les inégalités sociales et
puis de contribuer à l'élévation du
niveau général
donc c'est une ce sont de véritables
politiques publiques c'est à dire on
fait des choix on les assume
budgétairement est plutôt que de faire
pleuvoir les moyens de manière
indistincte aujourd'hui il ya eu
seulement environ 5000 suppressions de
postes de fonctionnaires qui avaient
déjà été annoncés
on voit plus de la moitié concerne notre
ministère est ce que à l'échelle des
50000 ça veut dire que vous allez avoir
plus de 25 mille suppressions de postes
sur votre mini ce nom alors non et non
d'abord nous n'avons pas cette année
plus de la moitié de celles ci vous fait
1800 euros 1800 en moins sur 5000 ça
fait plutôt intérêt oui même pas donc
c'est quand même
mode donc c'est moins les indiens sur 50
milles ça et par ailleurs il n'y a pas
de de deux projections de ce type moment
nous parlons vous avez justement sur les
réductions des fonctionnements le
batteur est ce que c'est aux toutous à
chaque rentrée il y aura donc des
effectifs en moins est ce que vous vous
êtes prêts ça sonne alors cas pas de
manière indistincte ça c'est sûr c'est à
dire par exemple y aura des md la chose
par exemple une chose que je suis
capable de vous garantir aujourd'hui
c'est le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de
suppression de postes dans le premier
degré et que même là nous continuons à
la rentrée prochaine les créations de
postes ce que je garantis par exemple
c'est que le taux d'encadrement à
l'école primaire dans notre pays va
s'améliorer dans chaque département de
france rentrés après rentrée et ça c est
lié et à la démographie et au choix
budgétaires que nous faisons tout
simplement parce qu'on veut à la fois
des classes dédoublées mais aussi un
taux d'encadrement qui s'améliore dans
toutes les classes de l'école primaire
de façon à tout simplement encore une
fois est-ce que nos enfants prennent un
bon départ à coeur dans leur vie
scolaire votre philosophie mais la
question portait sur effectivement les
projections en termes de baisse des
effectifs de la fonction publique
puisqu'il est un objectif qui a été fixé
par par le chef de l'état et vous y
contribuez donc et vous allez continuer
à le faire donc
année après année donc c'est une entorse
discute encore se discutent encore vous
pensez pouvoir sauver vos effectifs lors
des prochaines semaines nous expose la
soul ou alors est ce là que d'assumer le
fait aussi de dégraisser le mammouth de
dire les choses que alors je n'aime pas
cette expression parce que je ne me suis
jamais c'est le terme de pachydermes
préhistorique que vous avez utilisé
parce que je pense que ça nous fait du
tort d'utiliser ce mot puisque
précisément ce que j'essaye de démontrer
maintenant c'est que nous pouvons
réformer l'éducation nationale et lui
donner de l'agilité cette agilité nous
avons démontré qu'elle était possible
c'est que depuis 18 mois nous avons fait
le dédoublement des classes en moins de
trois mois
nous avons fait la réforme du
baccalauréat dont on parlait depuis des
décennies et qui c'est qui s'est
accomplie et que nous sommes en train de
mettre en oeuvre nous avons nous faisons
la réforme de l'enseignement
professionnel on va parler choisir la
forme des programmes donc nous avons mis
la machine en route
elle est en fait plus agile que ce que
l'on dit habituellement est en effet
dans les suppressions de postes il faut
savoir que les chiffres que l'on a
indiqué à l'instant son équipe qui
englobe des postes administratifs des
postes qui ne sont pas devant élèves
donc le donc en effet il ya des éléments
de réforme du fonctionnement derrière
cela rappelons que l'on parle de 0 2%
des effectifs dont vous parlez dans
l'encadrement l'école va peut-être
bientôt vous de voir encadré le code de
la route c'est emmanuel macron qu'il a
qui l'a annoncé ce que vous étiez au
courant de ces sept cette annonce est ce
que vous savez ça vous a surpris
qu est ce qu est ce que vous pouvez un
peu nous expliquer la façon dont ça
pourrait se passer alors c'est ans est
en train de ce travail est bien entendu
et l'autre sur les grands principes on
en a parlé évidemment avec le président
de la république
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose dont il
avait parlé pendant la campagne
présidentielle et nous ne partons pas de
zéro puisque vous avez une attestation
de sécurité routière que vous passez
quand vous êtes quand vous êtes élève
donc il est tout à fait normal
d'apprendre le code de la route quand
vous êtes élève et que cet enfant parce
que d'abord vous êtes piétons vous avez
certains enfants qui ont un permis
piéton même aujourd'hui et parce que
derrière le code de la route c'est aussi
un peu les valeurs de la république le
respect d'autrui
qui des règles de la vie en commun qui
sont derrière cela donc c'est très
éduquée c'est le rôle de l'école
d'apprendre le cas de la route je pense
qu'il ya un rôle qui malgrès il ya un
rôle qui va même un petit peu là c'est
que derrière qu'on apprenne ce qu'il y a
non seulement la lettre du code de la
route mais l'esprit du code de la route
qu'on voyait parfois les gens se
comportaient dans la voiture vous dites
qu'il ya un petit sujet éducatif en
amour et ça fait partie des choses qu'on
aurait enseigné aux enfants tradiction
quand même vous êtes quand même un
ministre qui porte le message de dire on
revient aux fondamentaux les maths le
français là on va apprendre le code de
la route à l'école est ce que alors ça
correspond à votre philosophie à la
alors aux blancs charisme oui dès lors
que c'est bien fait c'est à dire que la
la ça vous allez regarder quand même
avoir comme toute chose il faut avoir
une approche qualitative c'est à dire
c'est l'époux pas faire il faut jamais
surtout l'ensemble des choses
pertinentes
ils sont pas le coeur de la mission de
l'école qui est l'instruction il faut
toujours se dire comment ça vient
s'intégrer dans le coeur autrement dit
non ne juxtapose pas les choses je
pouvais vous citez 7 ou 8 m très
légitime que vous pouvez ajouter aux
missions de l'école comme la sécurité
routière mais aussi par exemple la lutte
contre l'obésité
bien se nourrir faire du vélo
toutes ces choses sont très légitimes
simplement à chaque fois qu'on les met
dans le système scolaire
il faut voir comment ça vient
s'articuler avec le fondamental et là en
l'occurrence le code de la route
ça vient s'intégrer avec respecter
autrui avec les valeurs de la république
avec des enjeux de vie en commun qu'il
ya à l'école donc c'est alors que c'est
bien fait c'est à la russie plus tout à
fait puisqu'on parle de la conduite
automobile est ce que vous redoutez une
coagulation des mécontentements des
frustrations dans d'autres pays avec le
mouvement samedi des gilets jaunes
non je pense que le hunt non je pense
qu'il ya des effets de miroir
grossissant dans dont l'écho médiatique
qui est qui est donnée à tout cela
chacun est un peu dans son rôle
on est dans une démocratie on a une
opposition qui cherche à la toujours
pointé les failles du gouvernement mais
après tout c'est peut-être normal dans
une démocratie des médias qui insistent
sur ce qui ne va pas c'est normal dans
une démocratie mais un gouvernement qui
accomplit ses engagements c'est normal
dans une démocratie même si on n'a pas
toujours été habitué à ça il ya
peut-être quelque chose de nouveau qui
étonne et on le voit dans mon domaine
comme dans d'autres
prenons le cas de agnès buzyn est en
train de réaliser
rien moins que l'équilibré des comptes
de la sécurité sociale pour 2010 9 chose
qu'on attendait depuis des lustres et
qui ne s'accomplit sait pas elle le fait
prenons muriel pénicaud et la prise des
lois dans le domaine du travail qui sont
eux aussi des engagements présidentiels
qui permettent à l'économie tout
simplement de créer plus d'emplois dans
les temps à venir c'est ça le but tout
ceci donc ce sont des exemples qui
montrent que ce gouvernement accompli
les engagements que le président de la
république avait pris mais je crois que
parfois ça étonne mais il faut que on
s'habitue à ça il ya remplir les
engagements il ya incontestablement une
colère qui gronde qui existent et qui en
particulier nenê ni contrôlées par un
parti politique par un syndicat mais qui
est un mouvement citoyen est ce que ça
na qu est-ce que c'est pas ça qui
pourrait inquiéter le gouvernement parce
que par définition ce mouvement n'est
pas contrôlable
d'abord il faut toujours écouter c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait le président
république en dance on dans tousles
l'itinéraire qu'il a fait à l'occasion
de la commémoration du centenaire et il
le fait très fortement et nous écoutons
tous beaucoup
encore une fois la semaine dernière
j'étais dans différentes parties de
france
nous écoutons nous savons bien qu'il ya
des choses qui se sentait comme un
savons bien qu'il ya des choses c'est ma
suleija il ya plusieurs points qu'il
faut quand même avoir l'esprit c'est
d'abord sur la plupart des choses qui
sont reprochés presque toutes sont des
choses qui n'ont pas 18 mois d'âge qui
s'est très souvent en dix ans voire
davantage
d'existence dans notre dans notre
société c'est parfois un petit peu
paradoxal de voir ce gouvernement qui
est là depuis 18 mois qui prend les
choses à bras le corps qu'ils se
retroussent les manches qui fait des
choses parfois difficile et courageux se
voir reprocher des éléments et compris
par des partis politiques qui eux ont eu
le pouvoir et qu'ils n'ont pas remédié à
cela
alors maintenant pour comprendre les
frustrations des français on peut
comprendre ce qui se passe du côté de
l'essence en particulier mais et mettez
donc savoir écouter savoir
éventuellement prendre les mêmes et leur
est nécessaire mais montrer qu'un quart
montrer qu'il ya 1 500 choses en matière
de décence d'abord il ya une
géopolitique mondiale chacun sait c'est
en grande partie du fait de cette
géopolitique que les prix ont monté ce
n'est pas la première la première fois
que ça nous arrive
il ya eu d'autres moments où les
naissances été aussi cher et par
ailleurs il ya une politique assumée par
ce gouvernement de transition écologique
qui est qui et équitation michel manca
vous avez évoqué plusieurs fois depuis
le début de l'émission les valeurs de la
république elles ont été célébrées hier
par le chef de l'état alors bien sûr de
la commémoration du 11 novembre
est-ce que l'école est encore
aujourd'hui en mesure bien inculquer de
défendre ses valeurs de la république
face aux problèmes que l'on voit dans
les établissements la laïcité contesté
et l'antisémitisme
écoutez il ya beaucoup de choses qui
était allée qui n'allait pas dans notre
système scolaire en la matière et qui
rendent les choses difficiles parfois au
quotidien non pas dans toutes les écoles
tous les collèges et les lycées mais
dans une partie des écoles et des
collèges de lycées de france
et là aussi c'est un sujet que j'ai
décidé de prendre à bras le corps dès
que je suis arrivé je rappelle que dès
que je suis arrivé c'est à dire en juin
j'ai commencé un a créé un système de
veille sur la laïcité des équipes
d'abord on n'a ni la règle en matière de
laïcité on a des équipes qui
interviennent dans les établissements
plus de 400 fois depuis depuis six mois
on a j'ai créé aussi bien en matière de
sécurité
est-ce qu'ils 1112 l'armature
d'établissement lié à cette surveillance
que vous avez mis en place dès 10h jeu
suivra à oui si vous vous évoquer la
question de la laïcité de la fermeture
oui bien sûr il en fait un bond et alors
alors attendez gars parce qu il ya
plusieurs sujets dans ce que vous dites
là vous êtes sur le si vous êtes sur la
laïcité est donc et notamment donc du
fondamentalisme islamiste tel qu'il se
manifeste par la création de structures
scolaires
enfin nous avons fait voter une loi pour
avoir l'outil juridique pour fermer cet
outil juridique n'existait pas c'est la
loi dite gatel qui a été voté donc en
juin dernier
c'est un point fondamental qui nous
permet maintenant de fermer par exemple
une école salafistes quand il y en a
donc il y a en effet attendre au cours
des prochaines semaines
des fermetures d'écoles de ce type en
respectant les règles de droit bien sûr
qu'ils sont qui reste rigoureuse tout de
même
mais oui bien entendu vous pouvez vous
attendre à ce qu'ils aient des
fermetures de ce type à ce que nous
devons nous inquiéter de la montée de ce
fondamentalisme islamiste sous la forme
soit de l'instruction à domicile soit de
la création d'écoles hors contrat de ce
type avec des comportements que vous
observez qui sont sectaires qui relève
de l'endoctrinement bien sûr qu'ils sont
tous les cas en dehors de ces fameuses
combien leur de la république qui vous
aiment octobre et je me garderai bien de
vous dire vous dire un chiffre de la
paix la chose que je peux vous affirmer
c'est que des fermetures et y en aura
nous sommes organisés pour cela et là
aussi on parte on arrive de loin sur ces
sujets et c'est des sujets sur lesquels
depuis le début j'ai juste une affiche
très clairement une fermeture est
indisponible d'ailleurs eu une fermeture
toulouse avant l'été merci messieurs
c'est la fin de la première partie
d'auditions publiques tout de suite nous
accueillons donc nos deux parlementaires
[Musique]
bonsoir je vous laisse vous installez le
temps de donner une question tient d'un
un internaute sur le figaro live c'est
antonin qui vous demande monsieur le
ministre comment est ce que vous comptez
remédier à la crise des vocations qui
aboutit à des recrutements de profs
moins qualifiés dit il c'est un problème
arrive sur ce un problème secours
j'ai en partie commencée il répond tout
à l'heure quand général et d'un
rémunération des professeurs de la
considération que nous devons tous aux
professeurs et commencer par le ministre
affirme en permanence et je demande à la
société française d'avoir cette
considération pour pour les professeurs
et c'est le respect des règles et aux
claviers les matériels immatériels mais
aussi le pré recrutement j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure c'est une réforme en
cours qui va avoir beaucoup d'importance
nous permettant d'amener des étudiants
qui ont la vocation justement de les
accompagner aussi financièrement pour
réussir les concours et être mieux
préparés d'accord dans le futur qu'au
jour avec nous donc ça lui a gagné
bonsoir sénatrice ps des bouches du
rhône est à vos côtés
patrick hetzel députés à l'ère du beurre
et vous connaissez très bien le
minispace que vous avez été au même
moment dans la même fonction recteur
monsieur le député votre situation c'est
après c'est vrai que tout à l'heure le
ministre disait qu'il creuse un sillon
j'ai envie de dire c'est tout de même un
peu un microsillon tout simplement parce
que aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
déclarations et on voit bien un certain
nombre d'enseignants un certain nombre y
compris d'élèves un certain nombre de
parents disent que et bien ça ne va pas
au fond des choses et aujourd'hui
moelleux l'énorme problème que je vois
c'est déjà la question de la violence en
milieu scolaire
et là dessus on voit bien il ya eu des
tâtonnements a misé de l'intérieur qui
dit on va des policiers j'aimerais bien
entendre le ministre
qu'est ce qu'il veut vraiment faire à ce
sujet qui ne soit pas simplement
cosmétiques
alors d'abord sur ce discours que
j'entends de la part de l'opposition
je répète normal en démocratie mais
enfin je savais que vous avez
un très fort soutien chez les
sympathisants et l'air encore plus
important que chez des sympathisants les
républiques en marche d'après le dernier
baromètre de paris match
oui mais j'ai regardé un peu sais pas si
c'est inquiéter l'air ou pas mais le
fait est que vous avez aussi des gens du
ps ou de france insoumise qui
soutiennent ce que je peux faire
alors ce que ça transcende les clivages
la violence les policiers à l'école
alors sur le alors sur la question de la
violence d'abord on arrive de loin c'est
une des illustrations de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire c'est
parfois paradoxales de se faire
reprocher une situation qu'on n'a pas
inventé depuis 18 mois et qu'on est en
train de prendre à bras le corps vous
n'êtes pas le premier pour ce qui était
déjà directeur général de l'enseignement
scolaire pardon c'est un peu facile
comme le nom mais en aucun cas porter la
responsabilité de la sécurité des
établissements dans ce cas là ne
m'interrompez pas là la violence nous
l'apprenons à bras le corps lorsqu'il ya
eu les événements de créteil j'ai réagi
immédiatement et avant même que ce soit
médiatisé l'élève concerné a été mis en
examen ils sont les deux ont été exclus
donc il ya eu strictement aucun laxisme
dans cette affaire par ailleurs nous
avons annoncé des mesures en deux temps
et nous assumons complètement le fait de
faire les choses en deux temps le temps
dit j'ai d'abord gouvernement non parce
qu'elle paye pas ce que parce qu'il ya
des sujets qui sont qui nécessite de ne
pas réagir à chaud qui nécessite de
travailler tout simplement
donc premièrement des mesures qui de
toute façon été préparés parce qu'on
n'attend pas cet événement pour pour
agir qui sont les mesures qui ont trait
à la classe et à l'établissement comme
par exemple signalement systématique et
le suivi systématique de chaque fait dès
lors qu'un professeur signale un fait
c'est indiqué dans un registre et il ya
un suivi en face d'eux en face de cela
d'autres mesures comme le renforcement
des équipes mobiles de sécurité pour
aider les établissements d'autres
mesures aussi comme ce qu'on appelle la
période probatoire c'est à dire le fait
que lorsqu'un élève a été exclu et qui
revient chaque jour il doit venir devant
le chef d'établissement pour faire un
point sur son attitude depuis qu'il est
rentré et donc je vous renvoie aux vins
mesure que j'ai annoncée
la semaine dernière mais dans un mois
environ c'est à dire vers la mi décembre
nous annoncerons et nous l'avons dit de
façon interministériel parce que ça
touche la police la justice les affaires
sociales des mesures qui ont trait aux
enjeux de des abords de l'établissement
mais aussi de la famille de ce que de la
parentalité puisque c'est quand même un
des grands enjeux ce qui se passe du
projet éducatif en famille et puis en
troisième lieu les structures dédiées
pour les élèves au comportement
inacceptable que l'on doit mettre dans
des structures dédiées pour trouver une
solution il compte amplement il rappelle
les polymères samia ghali ancien
ministre sur ce qu'on veut les y en a je
partage complètement et moi je suis pas
les jeux
tu pragmatique voilà donc quand les
choses vont bien ils vont me dire moi ce
que la seule chose que je pourrais vous
dire c'est la question de prendre des
contrats aidés
pourquoi on a retiré ses contrats aidés
dans l'éducation nationale alors qu'ils
étaient un peu plus pour pour l'école
une permettait justement d'éviter et
d'anticiper peut-être ce genre
d'événement parce qu'ils écoutent parce
que c'est des jeunes souvent ils sont
allés dans les cours de récréation ils
sont à la porte du collège ou du lycée
et donc ils ont eu un échange direct
avec les élèves et ça permet peut-être
d'anticiper ce genre de problème c'est
une je le regrette ça c'est le fait de
voir retirer ces contrats aidés qui
était vraiment un plus pour l'éducation
nationale alors plusieurs éléments de
réponses d'abord sur la question des
contrats aidés là aussi c'est quelque
chose qui a assumé par le gouvernement
nous pensons que il fallait diminuer non
pas en finir d'ailleurs mire diminuer le
nombre de contrats aidés parce qu'il n'a
mené pas à l'emploi les bénéficiaires
des contrats aidés d'où la politique
menée par muriel pénicaud d'avoir
désormais d'autres formes de contrainte
qui existent qu'on appelle les pecs
maintenant qui permet d'avoir beaucoup
plus de formation pour les personnes
concernées pour les amener à l'emploi et
donc c'est aussi sous cette forme là
qu'on voit qu'on va voir apparaître
aussi de l'aide supplémentaire dans les
structures dans les épaves et pecs
peuvent peuvent être utilisés mais
surtout là où nous utilisions le plus
les contrats aidés à l'éducation
nationale c'est pour l'accueil des
élèves en situation de handicap
alors forcément c'est vrai non pas dans
les écoles dans les écoles d'éducation
prioritaire je peux vous garantir qu'ils
n'étaient pas utilisés comme pour les
non j'ai pas dit que c'était pour
s'engueuler été aussi et cela est ce que
monsieur nice assuré moi sur cette
question je vous et vous avez raison je
suis d'accord avec vous simplement je
tiens quand même il ya deux éléments 1 1
si c'est un très grand nombre c'était de
l'ordre de 50 mille contrats aidés pour
l'accueil des élèves en situation de
handicap
nous en avons de moins en moins pour ça
puis nous les remplaçons par des
contrats plus robuste qu'on appelle des
aveux est sage et s'accompagnant
d'élèves en situation de handicap et c
est donc c'est des personnes qui
potentiellement peuvent être mieux payés
si elles sont à plein temps il nous
travaillons actuellement pour qu'elles
soient davantage à plein temps et mieux
formée avec 60 heures de formation par
an c'est donc une petite de nouveaux
plus qualitative qui d'ailleurs est en
train d'évoluer puisque nous avons en ce
moment même une concertation pour faire
évoluer le statut de ces personnes et
que le service public rendu soit
meilleure pour les élèves concernés sur
les contrats aidés de ceux qui est dell
et
directeur d'école très souvent c'était
des situations un petit peu bancal si
vous me permettez l'expression c'est à
dire il y avait un contrat aidé mais le
directeur d'école préfère une personne
stable avec un véritable contrat normal
nous en discutions avec les
collectivités locales pour appoint
arriver à un changement du statut de
directeur d'école et je présenterai une
loi au début de l'année prochaine sur
sur ces sujets de chaque fois que c'est
possible avoir d'autres contrats cas des
contrats aidés pour aider les directeurs
d'école mais je vous accorde volontiers
que nous sommes un peu dans un entre
deux et que c'est la fin du politique et
le début d'une autre et que l'endroit où
ça ne va pas d'accord patrick hetzel oui
dans les choses qui ne qui ne vont pas
je vous ai écouté notamment au printemps
dernier et on vous croyait sur sur
parole notamment sur la manière dont
vous utilisez vos moyens vous dites
priorité pour le premier degré tout le
monde est d'accord dédoublement des
clash
évidemment dans l'éducation prioritaire
tout le monde est d'accord
ceci étant il ya quand même une question
de moyens est ce qu'on voit c'est que à
certains endroits que vous le veuillez
ou non vous habiller paul mais vous êtes
vous déshabiller pierre et sa lumière
basse et la ruralité sans la ruralité et
autres ministères a publié les chiffres
il ya eu plusieurs centaines de
fermetures de classes à la rentrée en
ruralité
donc il ya un vrai problème et vous
évoquer les questions des taux
d'encadrement
il faut faire très attention parce que
par exemple les brigades de remplacement
vous avez dégrader les moyens de ces
brigades de remplacement ce qui veut
dire qu'on va sans doute avoir des
moments de tension dans les semaines qui
viennent pour les remplacements et puis
surtout vous le savez les remplaçants
ils sont aussi là pour permettre
justement aux enseignants du premier
degré d'être formés et tout ça ce sont
finalement des angles morts
votre point révolution inédite et c'est
juste faux c'est faux fait désolé
patrick adam c'est faux noms comme je
vais citer les chiffres volets fermés
si vous me laissez parler je vais alors
premièrement patriat lecteur m'a envoyé
à mes fonctions je vais faire une chose
quand il était recteur de limoges et le
plus de fermetures de classes rurales
que l'année dernière dans le même
rectorat de limoges est donc premier
oui sauf que ruralité les premiers
éléments de dons qu'il faut savoir faut
aussi avoir le sens des responsabilités
quand on fait des accusations paris
deuxièmement si taille des pneus non
massif patrick et elle fait quelque
chose qui n'est pas parfaitement honnête
c'était qui cite les fermetures sans
citer les ouvertures autrement dit le
système scolaire depuis toujours ferme
des classes et on ouvre en fonction de
la démographie médicale juste je le je
le rappelle non il ya un problème
démographique aujourd'hui en france
c'est vrai il manque 30 à 40 mille
enfants chaque année dans les naissances
c'est une réalité et c'est notamment
dans la rue dans la ruralité que l'on
constate si l'on te ne prenait en compte
pleinement cette baisse démographique on
fermerait beaucoup plus de classe et il
y en a jamais eu proportionnellement de
classe ont aussi peu fermé que ce que
nous avons fait l'année dernière voilà
où le faire et ça donne aujourd'hui vous
avez bon match probant non on a des
arguments très hâtivement il ya deux
visions et à l'interprétation il était
si près qu'il s'oppose samia ghali qui
veut parler aussi d'autres écoles en
milieu rural mais par exemple à
marseille à marseille monsieur le
ministre vous y est pas pour grand chose
mais j'espère que vous allez arriver à
aider les petits marseillais ce
marseillais à y voir plus clair
vous savez que la ville de marseille a
mis en place un ppp partenariat public
privé pour rénover pour en fait démolir
et reconstruire
trente trois écoles ça coûte 2 milliards
d'euros c'est deux milliards par an 1
milliard d'euros c'est énorme puisque en
fait surtout 10% des et ça représente 10
% du nombre d'écoles marseillaise
comment ce ppp
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
collectif qui s'est monté de parents
d'élèves de
d'enseignants
d'architectes de gens qui sont qui se
sont mobilisés des marseillais tout
court et qui ont travaillé sur le fond
de ce ppp en fait ce ppp coûterait il ya
300 millions d'euros qui serait de trop
si c'était la ville de marseille qui
faisait des travaux en sachant quand
même que les autres écoles et je vous
donne un exemple d'une école qui n'est
pas considéré qu'il n'est pas concerné
par le ppp les cordes de l'école
burgeaud dans le 3e arrondissement de
marseille
l'arrondissement où malheureusement le
plus pauvre d'europe qui cette école
pendant trois semaines parce qu'on peut
se battre sur est ce que les enseignants
il y en a assez passer des fois il cette
fois ils vont pas à l'école parce que
l'école les tremper parce qu'elle est
remplie d'eau et pendant trois semaines
ces enfants ne sont pas allés à l'école
donc ça veut dire combien de moments
vous faites des efforts pour dédoubler
les classes et moi je suis vous avez jeu
les red et vous l'avez fait je le dis et
en même temps ces enfants
malheureusement ne pourront pas l'école
c'est que je voulais vous demander
monsieur le ministre est de pouvoir
faire vous en tant que ministre de
l'éducation nationale un audit sur
l'état des écoles à marseille c'est une
nécessité pour qu'on sache exactement
quelle est la réalité des écoles et
qu'on se retrouve pas un jour je vous le
dis dans la même situation que ces
immeubles qui se sont effondrés
c'est les mêmes enfants qui voient leur
immeuble cd s'effondrer et qui voient
leur école
malheureusement inondées c'est plus
possible donc j'en appelle vraiment à
votre solidarité j'en appelle aussi à
votre je sais combien cette question
elle est important pour vous et là
vraiment c'est un prix d'un un cri
d'alarmé cris voilà de détresse d'une
marseillaise
j'entends très bien ce que vous dites
même la sénatrice le alors plusieurs
plusieurs éléments un tube ou ce qui est
évident que une compétence collectivités
locales qu'on doit respecter les lacs
aux munitions mais qu'on présente pour
ce live et bien sûr peut-être qu'elles
sont rapportés par la cena j'y viens
c'est bien il a une compétence de la
collectivité locale qu'on ne saurait
contester entente elle puis la
compétence de l'état sur sur tout le
reste
je suis conscient de ça je crois que la
mairie aujourd'hui est consciente de
cela et à engager les travaux qu'elle
vous et vous faites référence le
bien entendu je n'ai pas vocation à
m'immiscer dans dans les mécanismes que
la mairie
après vous êtes monsieur le ministre
vous avez des enseignants dont vous en
avez la responsabilité si l'homme est
enseigné dans de bonnes conditions vous
avez les élèves aussi qu'ils sont sous
votre responsabilité quand il est au
temps scolaire et donc de fait de ce
fait là c'est dans cette cadeaux dans ce
cadre là que je vous demande de faire un
audit de la situation marseillaise
j'allais venir
je suis tout à fait disposé d'autant
plus qu' on le fait on le fait ça nous
arrive de le faire dans différents
endroits
une perspective toujours coopérative
avec comme seul objectif et pas de
danger la commune on sait très bien
qu'il ya des grandes difficultés c'est
très bien de faire des choses ensemble
il ya eu tout un travail d'audit c'est
une information soit 0 le rectorat de
marseille a déjà beaucoup travaillé avec
la voix la ville de marseille dans les
temps passés ça a donné naissance au fil
des mois une construction et on est
évidemment je suis je suis toujours prêt
sur les enjeux de bâti scolaire non pas
à me substituer aux collectivités ce
serait une mauvaise année la question du
ppp quand même sur cette question elle
pose elle va poser un problème des
écoles qui vont être prêts dès c'est à
dire qu'on va appeler le promoteur enfin
celui qui aura construit d'école pour
lui demander si on peut réparer si peu
de réparer la chaudière et de l'autre
côté des écoles qui vont dépendre du
public
il va y avoir une déséquilibre quand
même entre ces écoles alors que ces
mêmes marseillais c'est ça qui pose un
moment on nous reproche sans arrêt ça
peut arriver de la part de l'opposition
de d'avoir un état qui veut faire à la
place des collectivités locales là on a
une claire dans ses toiles donc ce qui
est normal c'est que l'état soit en
soutien et il le sera aussi bien d'un
point de vue financier d'ailleurs
puisqu'il ya évidemment des subventions
qui sont prévus pour ces investissements
auprès des collectivités que du point de
vue des expertises et est évidemment
quelque chose qui a déjà été dit à la
mairie de marseille qui a pu déboucher
sur certaines décisions il ya un travail
entre le rectorat et la mairie tout à
fait prêts à accentuer cela pour des
problèmes peut-être que nous n'aurions
pas vu jusqu'à présent même si je pense
qu'on a une idée assez claire du bâti
aujourd'hui donc en tout cas je vous
manifestement une couverture centrée sur
le rail on l'aurait patrick adèle il ya
un autre sujet sur lequel j'aimerais
vous interrogez monsieur le ministre
vous savez que la prévention sanitaire à
l'école est quelque chose d'important
or en fait on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation où d'un côté il ya mis
le médecin scolaire pour 12 millions
d'élèves et aujourd'hui cette situation
elle est devenue extrêmement critique
les médecins eux mêmes se plaignent ils
font partie de vos personnels ils se
plaignent ils disent que ça ne peut pas
durer
d'autant plus que les problèmes
sanitaires sont de plus en plus
important des lieux à certains endroits
et madame la sénatrice évoque marseille
c'est là les endroits où cette question
se pose elle se pose effectivement à
différents endroits et là en fait c'est
un sujet sur lequel on ne vous entend
pas ce qui soutient qui est il faut le
gagner avec y compris les élus que nous
sommes alors il suffit de m'écouter pour
mon temps j'ai parlé beaucoup de ce
sujet là nous avons même sans même aller
dans il ya quelques mois avec agnès
buzyn dans une école pour annoncer ce
que nous faisions en la matière là aussi
c'est pas et c'est un sujet très anciens
très ancrée on manque de médecins
scolaires en france donc c'est pas parce
que nous ne maîtrisons pas les moyens
nécessaires c'est parce que y'a pas les
vocations pour aller sur les postes que
nous créons partout en france de
médecins scolaires
c'est un petit peu moins vrai pour les
infirmières scolaires mais c'est vrai
aussi
donc nous avons un prennent de vocation
d'une certaine façon
donc la solution que nous avons trouvée
avec agnès buzyn s'est impliqué aussi la
médecine civile dans cet enjeu et ça
joue la corde totalement fondamental qui
est la santé des enfants en réalité est
donc ce que l'oeuf l'objectif que nous
nous sommes fixés au cours des trois
prochaines années c'est d'arriver pour
de vrai ce qui n'a jamais été accompli
jusqu'à présent à la visite médicale de
tous les enfants de france entre 0 et 6
ans et notamment donc entre trois et six
ans de façon à ce que les problèmes de
santé qui peuvent exister notamment
l'ouïe la vue ou d'autres problèmes de
santé qu'on peut détecter la dénutrition
nutrition et les réseaux différents mais
le diabète et des enfants par exemple
sont de vraies questions
tous ces sourires détecter au mieux le
plus tôt possible c'est un impératif
catégorique franchement bien entendu à
la vigilance est intacte retable nous
nous sommes d'abord de gagner
oubliez intervenir on connaissait bien
les quartiers de marseille vous l'avez
c'est un instant avec les problèmes
d'insécurité de violence et d'autorité
des maîtres et là vous aviez envie de
nous des propositions oui je ne suis pas
monsieur le ministre sur la question de
l'école d'abord moi je suis favorable à
l'uniforme dans les écoles pourquoi
parce que quand on donne la prime de
rentrée scolaire
je sais que vous aimez je sais que vous
êtes favorable mais pourquoi parce que
quand on voit aujourd'hui que une partie
de la prime de rentrée scolaire est
consacrée à les acheter le survêtement
de marque la baskets de marque et ça
permettrait tout simplement de mettre
tout le monde au même niveau
je trouve que vraiment ça ce serait pour
moi formidable s'est demandé aussi dans
des parts par les parents dans les
quartiers difficiles pas ça éviterait
aussi aux parents à se retrouver dans
des surenchères de loterie la cei mangez
pas ça je pense c'est nécessaire la
question aussi pour moi qui est très
important c'est la question de la notion
du bien et du mal qui a disparu qui
n'est plus présente aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation qui n'est plus présente dans
l'éducation chez les enfants est quelque
chose qu'il faut absolument remettre à
l'ordre jour en parle souvent de laïcité
mais avant de parler de la licité aucun
gêne parce que ce qui s'est passé à
créteil par exemple je vais dire une
chose et ferment je ne cherche pas à
choquer mais c'est une et c'est
important de le comprendre
six jeunes là quand il est venu avec son
pistolet en plastique et ses grades ce
qu'il a fait et c'est grave mais lui
considère qu'au moment où ils voient des
kalachs où il voit des armes réelles
quand il vient lui avec son pistolet en
plastique il est gentil lui considère
pas qu'il a fait quelque chose de grave
alors que c'est grave
tout simplement parce qu'il a perdu il
ces notions et ces notions là elles n'y
sont plus là elles ne sont plus là est
la question si d'autorité parentale
l'article 371 1 2 du code civil en marie
les gens nous on est fiers de leur dire
ça qu'ils doivent ils sont responsables
de leurs des enfants qu'ils vont avoir
et pour autant lorsqu'il ya un problème
les parents ils disparaissent on a
l'impression qu'on a seulement des
enfants et autorise un appel très sévère
car l autorité et je vais vouloir encore
notre position c'est sur la question
notamment
moi je suis pas favorable à faire que
sur la question des allocations
familiales des prestations aider les
familles qui font le maximum mais celles
qui ne le font pas ils ne sont pas là
pour ça et souvent d'ondés père s'en
vont à l'étranger pendant 6 mois 3 mois
4 mois sans se poser de question de
savoir que font leurs enfants mais je
pense que là il faudrait les mettre sous
tutelle pour les accompagner et aider
l'enfant psy une façon d'aider enfants
c'est pour ça que sur la prime scolaire
je suis pour qu'on n'en reversent une
partie aux écoles pour pouvoir faire
l'aide aux devoirs pour dire si vous
êtes en accord total avec senna tout
d'abord d'abord vous êtes une
républicaine vous êtes très sincère je
partage une bonne partie de ce que vous
venez de dire je vous engage à tabou
aussi à convaincre les personnes de
votre parti politique de me soutenir
quand j'irai dans les directions vous
êtes en train de il est l'uniforme
l'académie de créteil était très molle
par rapport par exemple à la commune de
meaux très clairement le le maire de
meaux il voulait il voulait mondiale et
la situation était très tendue sujet
sicile et national de chevaux dont on
peut d'ailleurs la montée de mme le
maire pouvait m'appeler vous êtes là
haut niveau c'est pourquoi patrick gazé
chose s'emploie à quelques
contre-vérités puisque dans la même
académie de créteil à la ville de
provins dans laquelle il ya justement
l'uniforme bruit probable voilà j'ai des
provinces mais en fait ces provinces les
entraîneurs ont en effet remis un peu
soutane et c'est même un briquet d'abord
ça c'est fait c'est en train de se faire
et j'ai tant qu'il fait c'est d'éviter
que je soutenais donc alors de laisser
votre powered non justement c'est un
petit peu la bleue sujet précédent
c'est-à-dire que je j'ai déclaré que
c'était d'abord j'en fais pas l'alpha et
l'oméga de ce qu'il ya faire c'est un
sujet parmi d'autres bien entendu sur ce
sujet là j'ai dit que le que c'était
ouvert
c'est ainsi que ça a pu s'enclencher par
ailleurs nous allons prendre des
initiatives et je vous proposerai à l'un
et à l'autre d'ailleurs un de mettre
autant associés que vous le souhaitez
dans les quatre semaines qui viennent
notamment pour les pour les projets que
nous allons faire je pense que c'est des
sujets en réalité d'unité nationale
et quant aux lecteurs de des sanctions
financières contre les familles par
exemple il ya une alternance
c'est ce que vous avez alors oui ça
c'est également nicolas sarkozy hollande
qui dit effectivement il faudrait
prendre des mesures incitatives
financières contre les familles et
d'autres disent attention vous allez
encore plus s'enfoncer et des familles
dans la difficulté
c'est un débat qui est pour les quatre
semaines à venir pas et nous annoncerons
des mesures mais positionné deux jours
est ce que ce soit mais oui mais parce
que justement il faut faire des choses
pragmatique c'est à dire qu' il ya des
cas comme ceux cités par la sénatrice
qui sont des cas ou en effet à mon avis
il faut faire une pression sur les
familles d'autres il faut soutenir la
famille
et c'est cette ce distinguo qu'il faut
savoir faire il faut être pragmatique et
ne pas être naïf c'est très bien ce qui
me guide
merci pour ce débat courtois est animée
mais merci à vous et vous allez c'est
maintenant la place à nos deux
journalistes qui font leur entrée pour
la troisième partie d'auditions
publiques avec jean michel blanquer avec
nous donc rien de mancini à ludovic faux
bond soirée on va en reprendre
effectivement on va égrener j'ai envie
de dire les réformes de l'éducation
nationale que vous avez lancé qui sont
sur les rails cette qui vont arriver car
elles sont nombreuses les d'olic d'abord
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez évoqué
il ya quelques instants avec les
parlementaires
cette affaire d'agression à créteil avec
une professeur qui a été braqué avec une
arme factice par un lycéen
le gouvernement semblait décidé à agir
vite et fort après cette agression
on se souvient de christophe castaner
qu'ils étaient prêts à assumer le
ministre de l'intérieur la présence de
forces de l'ordre quand nécessaire au
sein des établissements nicole belloubet
la ministre de la justice semble est
elle plus réservés alors finalement
pourquoi ce plan at il été reporté parce
qu'on ne l'a jamais vraiment su et est
ce que vous nous confirmer surtout qu'il
sera bien présenté ce plan contre les
violences à l'école au plus tard le 15
décembre alors plusieurs choses mais
d'abord il y à la première partie du
plan a été annoncé je les fais très
solennellement et publiquement il ya une
dizaine de jours je distingue trois
choses les singles la classe
l'établissement et l'extérieur de
l'établissement
sur les deux premiers cercles
concentriques c'est à dire la classe et
l'établissement j'ai annoncé des mesures
qui sont extrêmement concrètes et qui
sont en vigueur dès maintenant j'ai les
ai indiqué aux recteurs les chefs
d'établissements les connaissent j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour dire à quel
point nous avons besoin de chefs
d'établissement et quel point la france
doit soutenir ces chefs d'établissement
parce que c'est un travail difficile et
est que justement ils sont en première
ligne sur ces enjeux on a besoin là
aussi d'unités du monde adulte sur ces
questions et donc je sens répéter ce que
je disais tout à l'heure il ya toute une
série de mesures qui ont été prises et
notamment le signalement systématique
la sanction proportionnée la
simplification du conseil de discipline
le renforcement des équipes mobiles de
de sécurité la période probatoire pour
les élèves exclus quand elle quand ils
reviennent les travaux de
responsabilisation si vous avez fait un
tag c'est vous qu'ils repeignaient des
choses comme ça donc tout ça ce sont les
mesures les plus consensuelles j'en
avais parlé déjà maintenant c'est un
sujet qui nous enchaîne très bien
j'aimerais bien qu'elle le soit autant
vous dites parce que s'ils voulaient à
chaque fois que je dis des choses comme
ça j'ai quand même une série de gens qui
vont en tirons pas l'air d'être dans le
consensus mais en tout cas des deux
premiers cercles concentriques sont si
je puis dire régler autrement dit
nettement affirmée et mis en
le troisième cercle concentrique par
définition suppose de deux d'être dans
la finesse de ne pas aller dans la
précipitation parce qu'il ya eu un
événement et du travail interministériel
donc police-justice affaires sociales
même sport culture sont associés à notre
réflexion un groupe de travail s'est mit
s'est mis en route pour faire cela avec
un parlementaire une mère un art une
rectrice et c'est donc en effet comme
annoncé vers la mi-décembre que nous
annoncerons ce plan mais je vous le
dirai dans la sérénité s'agit pas de
réagir à chaud non plus un événement
ça faisait un an et demi que nous
travaillons de toute façon sur ces
questions sur lesquelles il ya eu
quelques progrès d'ailleurs et est
maintenant bien nous par achevons ce
processus avec ce que nous allons
retrouver ceux qui disent faire entrer
des policiers dans les établissements
scolaires c'est un échec de l'éducation
non je ne ne seraient pas d'accord et ça
je dirais la même chose que tout à leur
pragmatisme et mon analyse t il y à des
endroits où ça peut se justifier
évidemment le but serait pas d'avoir des
policiers partout tout le temps ce
serait absurde de dire une chose
pareille
il ne faut pas s'interdire certaines
choses parce que je connais la réalité
je vais beaucoup dans les établissements
j'en ai connu beaucoup
j'écoute mes professeurs je sais
beaucoup de choses et donc je sais à
quel point dans certains cas c'est
pertinent et puis si on veut qu'on est
aussi une bonne relation entre notre
jeunesse c'est et les policiers et ben
il est important que parfois même en
font ils
il est l'habitude de côtoyer un policier
de manière je dirais serait nommé
l'autoritaire resterait celle du chef
d'établissement a entendu sa voix ce
soir sur le policier bien sûr
appartement on est dans un établissement
scolaire
on a les seins règles d'un établissement
scolaire je crois que personne ne
conteste cela est le chef c'est de
l'arabisme royal c'est qu'il s'est passé
à créteil pose aussi la question du
portable dans les écoles vous êtes
opposé une loi a été votée pour
l'interdire au collège est ce que dans
les faits c'est applicable cette
interdiction du portable à l'école
oui bien sûr et
revisitez beaucoup de collèges ces
derniers temps où s'est appliqué donc
normalement maintenant 100% des collèges
de france ont interdit le téléphone
portable
j'invite d'ailleurs tous le monde a
indiqué s'ils voient une exception elle
cessera
mais normalement normalement il n'y en a
plus ban ans en collège mélismes non
mais c'est une interdiction à 100% c'est
la loi tout simplement non parce que
parfois je compte je dis ça parce que je
vois tout souvent dubitatif quand je dis
ça mais quand je dis 100% des collèges
c'est 100% décollage et s'il y avait une
exception il serait anormal et elle
serait réglé et apprêtez vous avez vous
avez encouragé à l'interdiction au lycée
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir mis dans la loi
dans ces cas là si nous l'avons mis ce
que nous avons mis dans la loi c'est la
possibilité de le faire et je pense que
c'est raisonnable c'est-à-dire que nous
considérons que le halage du lycéen
c'est un des règles différentes qui
s'applique et que là aussi par
pragmatisme
chaque lycée est un cas particulier il
est normal que le lycée puisse décider
et obtenir l'adhésion de sa communauté
éducative sur une sujet sur un sujet
comme ça donc j'ai j'ai invité à ce que
ce soit le cas mais ça peut pas être une
interdiction aussi rigoureuse que à
l'école primaire et au collège ce qui
est déjà une mesure qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre qui d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses j'en profite pour le dire et
regardé par le monde entier les très
nombreux pays se disent tiens la france
à peut-être fait là quelque chose qu'on
devrait imiter et de vic
alors vous faites peut-être partie de
ceux qui considèrent que le portable
contribuer à affaiblir le niveau des
élèves
on a eu les résultats il ya quelques
semaines d évaluation n'est en cp et en
c1 avec des résultats concernant le
français et les mathématiques qui ne
sont même pas très bon pour les élèves
français au delà du constat
comment est ce que vous comptez
rectifier le tir il ya une stratégie
d'ensemble pour l'école primaire et tous
les points sont complémentaires les uns
par rapport aux autres
vous avez d'abord eu un quelques
ajustements des programmes pour bien
remettre certaines choses dans laxe
notamment la concentration sur les
savoirs fondamentaux
par exemple conjuguer tous les verbes à
tous les temps à toutes les personnes
les quatre opérations plutôt que ça
n'était prévu toute une série de
recommandations pédagogiques qui
permettent d'avoir des points de repère
pour les pour les enseignants j'indique
d'ailleurs à tout le monde que
aujourd'hui sur un site qui s'appelle
eduscol vous pouvez voir ce qu'on
appelle les points de repère année après
année que nous avons publié pour
consultation et qui donc vont devenir le
après les modifications que nous ferons
pour réagir aux aux différentes
propositions et critique qui seront
faites qui vont devient devenir le point
de repère de tous y compris d'ailleurs
des parents sur ce qu'on attendait en
quelque sorte c'est là encore il ya des
réticences j'entendais l'épreuve
certains l'attendent et si on a une
fonction individuelles disaient qu est
ce qu on leur répondait il ya jeunes ont
des choses ne se pose pas comme ça je
pense qu'il ya une très grande liberté
des professeurs et j'y tiens il ya
autant qu'eux ils la gardent bien
entendu mais par contre ce qui est très
important c'est d'avoir un cadre il est
professeur sont les premiers à le
demander
les professeurs de terrain demande ça je
parle avec eux tous les jours je sais
très bien ce qu'ils veulent a fortiori
quand vous êtes un jeune professeur vous
êtes contents de savoir que
l'institution vous dis bon bah c'est
voilà ce qu'il faut acquérir cette année
que l'année d'après ce sera ça et ça
vous sert de point de repère à gré quand
il sera préservé des marges de manoeuvre
considérable qu'on voit une manière de
faire même la frontière sur la lecture
bien sûr qu'il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent mieux que d'autres et je
serai en dans mon tort si en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale d'un
service public national de 12 millions
d'élèves
je ne disais pas ce que la recherche la
comparaison internationale nous disent
sur ce qui fonctionne bien en lecture ou
ce qui ne fonctionne pas et donc je le
dis et les évaluations évidemment
traduit cela c'est à dire les
évaluations sont une innovation majeure
c'est tous les élèves de cp tous les
élèves de ce1 les ont passés il ya
quelques semaines
ces deux fois huit cent mille élèves
c'est beaucoup et bien on a aujourd'hui
dans toutes les écoles de france
vous avez le résultat de ces évaluations
élèves par élève
ce qui permet à chaque professeur de
l'école primaire de pouvoir parler avec
les parents sur ou en et l'enfant mais
d'une manière non seulement totalement
dédramatiser mais purement positive
si la lire comment est-ce qu'on va
travailler cette année pour faire que
votre enfant avec les caractéristiques
qui louait la puisse progresser tout
simplement ya aussi des évaluations dans
les collèges dans les lycées est ce que
là vous avez les chiffres oui on
des évaluations de début de sixième et
des évaluations de début de seconde
on n'a pas encore agréger les chiffres
nationaux parce que c'est des choses qui
prennent du temps sur les 6e et les
seconds en revanche c'est disponible
dans le shaq dans chaque établissement
et c'est le but principal notre but
n'est pas d'avoir des statistiques
nationales ons on en a par d'autres
manières
ce qui nous importe le plus c'est à quel
point ça sert d'outil utile enfant
parent enfant parce que le constat c'est
que effectivement le niveau a baissé et
que la situation est grave
le constat c'est qu'on a toujours mêlé d
erreur oui on peut le dire mais rien n'y
allez pas ce matin nationaux les juin
alors on a notamment entre 20 et 30%
selon qu'on garde mathématiques français
en particulier entre 20 et 30 % des
élèves qui ont des acquis très fragile
et c'est bon c'est si je n'ai qu'un seul
sujet c'est celui là c'est mon sujet
principal et donc nous sommes en train
de manière très pragmatique de nous
donner les outils
ça passe par les évaluations ça passe
par les programmes ça passe par les
manuels ça passe par la formation des
professeurs et l'évaluation des
professeurs passent aussi par la
formation et l'évaluation des
professeurs bien sûr il y à une réforme
de la formation des professeurs qui est
en cours c'est un des objets de la loi
qui viendra en début 2019
et bien entendu c'est pour donner plus
de force aux pressions aujourd'hui vous
pouvez être formé dans telle partie de
la france ou dans tel autre
dans un cas vous allez recevoir 10
heures de cours sur comment est ce qu'on
apprend à lire un enfant dans un autre
de la recevoir 70 heures c'est
totalement anormal honda c'est des
sujets extrêmement sérieux qui nécessite
du temps de l'énergie des moyens et nous
voulons que tous les professeurs des
écoles et tous les atouts en commençant
leur carrière que devait il ya une autre
réforme qui est en cours qui commence
même à s'appliquer c'est la réforme du
bac et les programmes dans les lycées
certains dénoncent une réforme improvisé
avec une refonte des programmes qui va
qui va trop vite
est ce que vous ne voulez pas faire trop
de choses en même temps nous ont
beaucoup de choses mais ces dénis tron
c'est le lit trop de choses ni trop
rapide
d'abord sur la réforme du baccalauréat
engagements présidentiels en 2016 2017
annonce du premier ministre dans sa
déclaration de politique générale juin
2017 pour juin 2021 seul appel passé à
précipiter c'est quatre ans donc le
baccalauréat s'appliquera en juin 2021
mais vous avez un compte à rebours pour
l'année terminal demi
20 2021 est l'année de premières 2019
2020 et dès maintenant l'année 2018 2019
commencent à se caractériser car par
quelques petits changements pour les
seconds
le vrai grand changement c'est la
rentrée prochaine en 2019 qui est
préparée bien entendu et qui est surtout
un souffle nouveau fantastique pour le
lycée français de dépeignant pas angry
quelque chose qui est absolument
formidable qui était attendue depuis des
années par toute une série d'acteurs
tout simplement beaucoup de raisons la
première c'est plus de choix pour le
lycéen se fin des séries s es et l es
possibilité de choisir des spécialités
arrivée de nouvelles spécialités par
exemple six ans informatiques et
numériques possibilité d'approfondir
davantage des programmes qui en effet
viennent d'être recomposée autres les
projets sont fait là aussi j'invite
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui nous écoutent
tous nous regarde a gardées puisqu'ils
sont en consultation actuellement c'est
le site eduscol tous à chacun peut voir
ce que l'on a fait et cela ce sont des
programmes qui vont permettre d'élever
le niveau c'est bien le sait bien le but
sur les spécialités les élèves peuvent
choisir une spécialité spécialité qui
n'est pas forcément enseigné dans leur
lycée ce qui inquiète les enseignants
est ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
créer une usine à gaz pour les
proviseurs et pour les équipes
éducatives n'en ont créé un système de
choix et de liberté c'est ça ce qui le
caractérise
vous avez la possibilité vous avez 12
spécialités qui ont été définis vous en
avez 7 que vous trouverez dans chaque
lycée de france et par rapport à ses 7
vous pourrez en avoir une ou deux en
plus dans tel ou tel lycée pour des
raisons qui sont à étudier sur chaque
carte pour vous justement aider certains
lycées être plus attractif avoir des
complémentarités entre entre lycées cela
va permettre au lycée d'être un petit
peu plus autonome pour définir leur
projet éducatif de créer du désir du
désir pour l'élève
parce que c'est beaucoup plus désirable
de créer sa combinaison de spécialités
plutôt que d'aller dans un couloir
il y aura plus de passerelles si vous
avez fait un choix en première que vous
voulez changer en terminale ce sera plus
simple vous allez plus approfondir
quelque chose que vous désirez davantage
vous savez moi les seuls discours triste
que j'entends en ce moment des acteurs
de terrain
c'est les ice et les élèves de première
et de terminale qui me disent on est
bien malheureux ne pas avoir le bénéfice
de cette réforme du baccalauréat qui
concerne les élèves de seconde et elle a
été très concertée
on a écouté plus de 40 mille lycéens
dans la consultation qui a eu lieu tous
les acteurs les professeurs les
organisations syndicales que j'ai reçu
beaucoup
pour cela donc c'est quelque chose qui
vient absolument pas improviser c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ont au contraire
été très travaillé et très
collectivement néanmoins l'une des
grandes nouveautés de cette réforme du
bac c'est le contrôle continu qui
comptera pour 40% de la note finale et
certains s'inquiètent finalement de la
création ou l'accentuation d'un bac à
plusieurs vitesses qui accentuerait les
différences territoriales les
différences sociales selon les
établissements qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
leur répondre que nous avons fait tout
ce qu'il fallait pour objectiver ce
contrôle continu vous savez aujourd'hui
vous passez des bacs blancs quand vous
êtes en première ou en terminale
d'une certaine façon c'est quelque chose
qui est voisin de cela et qui va nous
permettre tout simplement de dire à tous
les élèves de france ce qui compte
certes c'est l'examen final que vous
passez entre parenthèses vous passez sur
deux spécialités que vous avez choisi
donc sur vos points forts sur des choses
que vous aimez et que vous avez
approfondie plus sur la philosophie et
sur une épreuve orale développer vos
compétences orales c'est un sujet
essentiel pour la france pour les jeunes
français et donc on leur dit ça en
contre le terminal ces quatre là et on
leur dit aussi tout le reste vous le
passez en contrôle continu c'est-à-dire
vous le passé non pas dans quelque chose
qui vous stresse sur une semaine qui
devient une espèce de psychodrame du
mois de juin que parfois perdre
certaines personnes ne prennent pas au
sérieux mais c'est au contraire votre
travail continu sur les années de
première et terminale qui va être
présente dans les faits tout au long de
l'année à ce que le contrôle continu ce
n'est pas soumettre les professeurs un
peu plus à la pression des parents
d'élèves non je propose je pense que
c'est le presque le contraire c'est à
dire qu aujourd'hui on est sur les
professeurs sont soumis à toute une
série de pressions liées à la réussite
au baccalauréat ce que feront les élèves
ensuite dans l'enseignement supérieur
tout ce que nous avons fait y compris le
nouveau mécanisme parcours super fait
pour avoir une vision beaucoup plus on
continuum de ce qui arrive à un enfant
et un adolescent dans sa façon de se
préparer à ce qui peut se passera
ensuite si je dois résumer la réforme du
baccalauréat je dirais en une phrase
c'est ce qui permet en préparant le
baccalauréat de préparer ce qu'il ya
derrière le baccalauréat celle inverse
du bachotage c'est au lieu de faire
chose d'un peu artificiel ont fait
quelque chose qui préparent des
compétences dont on va avoir besoin dans
la vie par exemple vient s'exprimer par
exemple avoir bien approfondie certaines
certaines matières donc on sort de
l'artificialité et on sort aussi des
effets de seuil des effets ou
ou s'est il ya un instant t il vous fait
passer d'une situation d'une autre alors
que ce qui est important c'est de cette
affaire les choses beaucoup plus en
continu y compris dans vos mécanismes
d'orientation vous avec la réforme du
lycée professionnel qui doit entrer en
vigueur à la rentrée prochaine en 2019
favorise l'apprentissage mais diminuent
les heures d'enseignement général est ce
que ce n'est pas contradictoire avec
l'acquisition d'un certain de savoirs
fondamentaux qui est défendu par ce
gouvernement que vous défendez vous même
non parce que de nouveau la question
n'est pas quantitative mais qualitative
si le sujet était quantitatif le lycéen
professionnels de francs serait le mieux
préparé de france et même d'europe 1
lycéens professionnels aujourd'hui à 34
heures d'enseignement par semaine ce
n'est pas c'est pas ça qui fait
fonctionner qui fait réellement
progresser ce qui fait progresser c'est
ce qui permet qualitativement d'avancé
donc oui il faut de l'enseignement
général en lycée professionnel bien sûr
je le défends sa très fortement mais ce
que nous avons fait c'est d'ailleurs
quelque chose qui a un coût mais que
nous assumons parce que nous pensons que
c'est bon qualitativement qui est là qu
intervention c'est à dire de
l'enseignement général et l'enseignement
privé un professeur d'enseignement
général et un professeur d'enseignement
professionnel ensemble dans une même
séquence pour que justement les élèves
de lycées professionnels qu un esprit
pratique surtout puisse s'améliorer en
français ou en mathématiques à partir
d'exemples concrets pas sacrifier la
formation du citoyen donc un ancien de
l'organisation là dessus non mais parce
qu il ya beaucoup de discours inexactes
sur sa jambe observe d'ailleurs que sûr
puisque vous parlez des syndicats que
sur lycée professionnel la moitié des
syndicats présents dans l'enseignement
professionnels n'ont pas voté contre ce
lorsque s'est passé en conseil supérieur
de l'éducation l'ont bien compris
je dirais l'intelligence de cette de 2,7
de cette évolution donc moi j'ai un
message très clair vis-à-vis
d'enseignement professionnel c'est que
c'est d'abord une de mes plus importante
priorité c'est la deuxième après l'école
primaire
je le dis clairement et nettement je
considère que si nous réussissons cette
réforme qui a pour vocation de faire
envie
de faire que des élèves vont aller dans
l'enseignement professionnel non pas du
fait de leur butin autres mais du fait
de leur désir de nouveau que l'on va y
retrouver les nouveaux métiers du
numérique de la transition écologique du
bâtiment de l'énergie
l'hôtellerie restauration tout un tas de
domaines dans lesquels il ya du travail
eh bien avec muriel pénicaud est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'on a fait ensemble sur
l'apprentissage est ce qu'on est en
train de faire avec l'enseignement
professionnel nous voulons tout
simplement préparer nos enfants à avoir
un travail à s'insérer dans la vie et à
être bien formés avoir des compétences
solides au regard des dernières
questions
les épreuves du baccalauréat doivent
être passés en français c'est ce que
vous avez répondu aux élèves du lycée
diwan de carhaix dans le finistère qui
avaient rédigé leur épreuve de maths en
breton alors ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi les bases pour une dérogation
pour passer leurs épreuves de maths en
basque est ce que vous pouvez leur
expliquer oui très simplement
moi je n'ai rien contre les langages et
même vous faire une révélation
j'étais inscrit en breton quand j'étais
en terminale donc on peut pas me
soupçonner de ne pas aimer l'engagement
c'est très important
j'ai d'ailleurs onglet soutenu
simplement d'abord ça ne sert à rien de
comparer les l'engrais jeu parce que si
on regarde ça on pourrait voir aussi des
choses que les bretons et que les bases
et dans l'égalité tomber le point sur
lequel je suis radical sans concession
possible
c'est je ne fais pas des concessions
rétroactive autrement dit c'était
c'était très clair que les mathématiques
se passer en français ils l'ont ils ont
voulu rédigé en breton et une fois
qu'ils l'ont fait ils me disent mais
pourquoi on n'a pas le droit de le faire
si j'accepte ça ça veut dire que je peux
accepter rétroactivement tout je ne
fonctionne jamais sous la pression est
donc sur ce sujet comme sur n'importe
quel autre donc ce n'est pas un sujet
contre leurs tongs contre l'engagement
le sujet de principe
c'était la règle ils n'ont pas respecté
la règle vous n'agissez pas sous la
pression même des sondages j'ai vu que
le dernier baromètre ifop pour paris
match vous faisait encore grimper là
votre image qui renforce encore donc
vous faites un lien avec votre boulimie
de réforme est ce que vous avez encore
envie de grimper
vous êtes le quatrième ministre le mieux
placé dans ce baromètre votre objectif
c'était peu non non c'est pas premier
vous savez ce que j'ai comme objectif
c'est de tracer un sillon est d'accord
sur plusieurs années de manière claire
le plus possible partagé par les
français
c'est la seule chose qui me fait plaisir
dans ce que l'on dit c'est le fait que
ce que je souhaite c'est créer l'école
de la confiance et donc d'avoir une
adhésion de la société française et
aussi des professeurs bien entendu et
des personnels qui travaillent pour
l'éducation que toute cette société
française soit unie autour des enjeux de
l'éducation
c'est pour ça que j'avais besoin
d'expliciter merci d'être venu alors
pour cela aujourd'hui avec no mercy
beaucoup jean michel blanquer
merci à vous merci à tous à la semaine
prochaine